hey guys welcome back to the new
rockstars blue dungeon i am eric voss
and i am going to be reacting to
a new trailer for the justice league
snyder cut and hbo max released
by zack snyder this morning there were
some very exciting reports from vero
that this was going to be happening
today
and it's one of the bright spots on the
2021 calendar that is giving us hope
though and since that first trailer came
out during dc fandom
we've heard all kinds of interesting
reports from zack snyder that like jared
leto joker is going to be coming back in
this
i'm so pumped to see what's going to be
in this trailer so i'm going to be
reacting to it in real time and then
giving you some thoughts on the new
stuff afterwards here
we go
no that is leonard cohen's leah and that
is a song that um
loves to get copyright stricken on
youtube even uh
the warner brothers studio youtube
channel had to take the trailer down
is this just like the same trailer as
before but it's in black and white
god damn it i hope there's some new
stuff in here okay here's what we're
gonna do i'm gonna listen to the audio
i'm not gonna share it with you because
i don't want this video to get taken
down
but for that first trailer breakdown i i
went deep into the lyrics of leonard
cohen's aliyah and i feel like i know it
in my head by now so
just bear with me i'm gonna do my best
to zoom it along for you
and you're gonna deal with it cool heard
there was a
secret chord that david played
and it pleased the lord and you don't
really okay so yeah we know that shot
there's a joker card there this is the
ruins of wayne manor thomas wayne showed
up there
yeah and dudes like this
is a temple of athena that's the arrow
that they fired to warn her oh that's
new
that's a new shot okay lived the baffled
king room frozen hallelujah
same stuff in the trailer cyborg on
football days
oh this is new okay oh okay so vic's
watching the
kids in the street that must be new
[Music]
barry saves uh iris west here my best
it wasn't much i couldn't feel
so i had to hug superman's mom
the truth i didn't come
to fool ya nope cue everyone getting
pissed off oh that's new too
oh they swapped them out okay cool
there's assad there
went wrong though struggling before the
lord of songs
on my tongue
oh i think that shot's new too yeah
huh steppenwolf looks so much better in
this
could be speed force there i'm curious
to see what that is
all right it's just black and white
that's
a brand new trailer all fresh
actually we'll let you listen to the
audio version of uh this last part
because i don't think it's the music
underneath so we'll just let the boys
talk
this guy's probably fought hundreds of
thousands of other super beings on the
other planets he's destroyed right and
we have to assume he's won i don't care
how many demons he's fought and how many
hells
never fought us not us united
us united give us a release date
no come on
damn it you could have at least given us
a month of 2021.
2021's 12 months you know what could
happen between now and just any month in
okay look uh it sounds like this is what
zack snyder always envisioned doing he
did cut a version of
justice league his version of justice
league uh with deborah when he talked
about this being
in all black and white so it sounds like
he's just delivering that there are
some new shots in here i'm gonna go
through what um new things that we're
able to determine from this obviously if
he spent all the time
recoloring the footage i don't think
we're going to be seeing like a black
and white episode we might but i feel
like there is also a lot of rich detail
to bring out just with color and with
contrast all that
gives you tone it gives it makes the
superman black suit look so much cooler
when there's color all around him so i
don't think they're just gonna put that
all in black and white and uh say what
you will
about uh the way people use leonard
cohen's eyelid i think that guy even was
like
we're done you putting this in movies
and in tv shows but it is thematically
pretty cool to link with this idea of
justice league coming back on hbo max
because like leonard cohen's original
intent with the music was that
it's some artists trying to find meaning
in these
repeated things that have been
reinterpreted by different people
through the ages
and then as he's trying to connect with
it he's just like i don't really even
know what this means anymore
and that's why you have that pause where
he's like it's a proud and it's
broken hallelujah
because that's what we kind of feel you
know if you're sitting in that back pew
of church and everyone's singing this
song and you're just like maybe if i
just keep singing that
i'll find meaning of it and then he
repeats hallelujah over and over and
over again
and by the end of it it's like well i i
guess i did
kind of find a meeting and it even if
the author
didn't really intend it to begin with
it's kind of what the theme of new
rockstars is but like there is still
meaning in that in the same way that
there is still meaning in zack snyder
taking this stuff that uh he handed off
to someone else and they
interpreted it their way and he's like
no i'm gonna take it back and i'm gonna
show you what i originally meant by and
hopefully through us re-piecing stuff
together we'll find a new meaning of it
and we'll all be able to celebrate that
but anyway i'm going to break down the
new stuff but before i
do a quick word about what we're doing
over at our new merch store aka the epic
hero shop
that is where we've got the stuff to let
you be your own hero by sporting the
coolest nerd inspired designs we are
having a black friday through cyber
monday 10
off sale that is 10 off everything in
the shop
it's great for gifting the heroes in
your life or you know just getting a new
t-shirt or hoodie for yourself because
you're the hero of your life you deserve
it we still have a few
mandalorian-inspired latest obsession
this
is the way shirts available though those
are selling out real quick and to
celebrate our first black friday we are
dropping a bunch of new designs that are
available for order starting on black
friday november 27th my favorite of
course is the new easter egg
line this one specifically is
celebrating the upcoming release of
wandavision and it is chock full of
easter eggs that were snuck into the
design and you know i can't resist a
hidden detail and there are over a dozen
in that one shirt and uh boom you
looking for this
literally now a boom you looking for
this shirt will be available for
pre-order starting black friday so you
can live that doncil meme life my
friends
other exciting new designs will be
dropping black friday too so keep an eye
out
all new designs will be available to
order or pre-order starting friday
november 27th so set aside those turkey
leftovers for a minute and head
to the epic hero shop at
newrockstarsmerch.com but
wait there's more use the code new
rockstars black at checkout for an
additional five percent off what a deal
so make sure you head to the epic hero
shop at new yorkers merch.com on black
friday to load up on some
heroically great gear okay uh from what
i can tell from this footage it looks
like there are
three maybe four or maybe five new shots
that zack snyder worked into the editing
here the first one is this shot of a
superman the
hollow projection and based off of other
pictures i think this hollow is being
projected from like the cyborg's head
r2d2 style interestingly it looks like
superman has kind of a pinstripe
cape in this projection but yes uh
presumably this is a moment the justice
league are
regrouping and they're reflecting back
on what they have lost by losing cal-el
and it sounds like in the
zeiss snyder re-edit of justice league
we're gonna see cyborg and flash go to
star labs and that's gonna be the
process by which
they bring back superman and speaking of
cyborg one of the other new shots is the
shot of victor stone looking out the
window sadly as some kids are playing
football in the
street for me i think one of the most
exciting of these episodes is gonna be
the ray fisher victor stone cyborg
episode we're gonna see more the
flashbacks of his football days how he
got injured how he recovered from that
how he was
reborn essentially a cyborg and really
dig more into his character because yeah
sadly the theatrical cut really just
kind of
left all that out now one of the most
interesting new shots in this
trailer is uh this shot from actually it
was in the theatrical version
but it had steppenwolf there this was
the ancient battle on earth it's when he
was like yeah bring it and he's got uh
he's surrounded by all these like
minions from from apocalypse but here it
looks like zack snyder has swapped in
dark side slash uh uxis or axis that's
how he's going to be known that's his
original name but what i like about this
switch is that we're going to get to
know
more of the ux's character and what
motivated him
and steppenwolf to target earth and i'm
hoping that maybe one of those figures
could be hegra the the mom
and that's why they're called mother
boxes we might get some clarity on what
their goals are and
why they're so intent on getting these
three boxes because they contain the
spirit of hegel and then right after
this we cut to this new guy this is uh
dasad
he might be uh one of the other minions
back there too he's gonna be part of
this whole royal
drama between ux's and steppenwolf hegre
and uh i believe the
last new shot that i can determine but
again this probably deserves more
exploration is this shot of
the machine guns on the batmobile they
they look pretty goddamn sick
i know uh many people criticize this
version of batman for uh using
machine guns a bit too much but hey he
is a attacking pair of demons how many
demons and how many hells well who cares
they're all getting mowed down
but it is worth remembering that a pair
of demons are like a transformed fallen
soldiers of the armies that uh
darkseid has conquered you know and all
these superhero uh movies they
they tend to just have like their foot
soldiers whether it's the outriders of
uh the avengers movies they're so
uninteresting to me when they're
just you know monster foot soldiers when
they're pawns that are just you know
there to
pile up into bodies and then scrape at
you that's not how armies really work
there they're composed of uh
people with personalities i had friends
on the death star you know so
i would hope that uh zack snyder's
justice league brings in uh more the
back story of how
they got armies like that and what it
really means to be a parademon um some
other updates we have gotten since dc
fandom the biggest one being that uh
jared leto joker will be part of this
apparently but he is gonna have a
different look um zack snyder believed
to use the term
road weary um which i'm i'm not really
sure what that means but i guess that
means maybe one that uh isn't really
excited to be his gangster who's
flirting with harley quinn and
doing a lot of weird sexy honkonka stuff
but uh one that's just a bit
more grounded and a bit sadder because
if anything everyone in zack snyder
movie needs to be sad
but another cool detail that zack snyder
mentioned is that we will see more of
robin's
story that whole hahaha jokes on you
detail from batman v superman
and that we might actually see the death
that led to that moment and yeah that
would be a very cool just
i think ultimately guys the fact that
we're doing this as a mini series
is the right way to go i i in general
whenever we make a movie there's so
much expectation on that movie delivery
delivering everything we need in three
acts under two hours and we're satisfied
but like in the same way that these
comic series are
you know multi-episodic events and then
we can spend more time
exploring tangents and just doing
character development that's kind of the
way i want to consume this content i
look at you know compare it to
mandalorian versus erisa skywalker
skywalker was kind of disappointing just
because they tried to cram
all these things in there and tie up all
these things uh answer questions we
didn't really care about
whereas the mandalorian can just have a
filler episode with ice spiders and
we're willing to forgive it uh while it
just kind of wanders its way and
explores its themes and gives its
characters time to breathe and grow and
that's what i think zack snyder is going
for with this snyder cut is just take
your time
uh include the shots you can be a bit
more indulgent uh
and follow loose threads and see where
they go
and then by the end of it we just feel
like we've had a like a four course meal
and that we enjoy it and we appreciate
it more as opposed to
saying oh did it uh deliver everything
that we wanted it to deliver it's like
well it delivered some things it gave us
other things we didn't expect and we're
just happy that we were part of this
ride so uh let me know what you thought
of this
new trailer in the comments below what
you're most excited to see for the
justice league next year the wrongs that
zack snyder will write again uh check
out our merch store at
newrockstarsmerch.com you can follow me
at ea boss follow me rockstars and all
social media hit that notification bell
when you subscribe to this channel
and i'll see you next time bye
[Music]
you